it is a challenging week it's the Easter
weekend now as you know it's a hot
weekend there's a lot going on in London
right across London and every day we've
had over a thousand officers in fact I
think it's probably now over 1,500
officers working to police these
protests it's had an impact not just on
the police obviously but on Londoners in
general lots of people have had
miserable disruption to their lives and
I've got one message for the protesters
and that is please go to Marble Arch
where you can protest lawfully stop
you're unlawful protest and if you don't
want to go to Marble Arch then go home
now what sympathy do you have for
businesses in the West End who by the
end of all of this will have lost tens
of millions of pounds in revenue I think
all all Londoners will have sympathy for
those businesses some will be able to
cope with their losses better than
others no doubt but it is clear that by
stopping for example Oxford Circus and
stopping the through route up from
Waterloo Bridge it's affecting business
in in all kinds of ways and people are
losing money it's also affecting people
who want to get about London whether
that's for work or tourist reasons it's
affecting everybody in the area of the
West End and I've been walking about
there today I can assure you that many
people are very fed up they're coming up
to me saying you know these protesters
don't realize they've you know the
impact they're having on people like me
have you been stung by the criticism
with people saying that this should have
been dealt with on day one police should
have just gone in and whatever a number
of arrests just kind of dealt with it
because of the impact on the city
commuters business and the international
reputation people looking in and seeing
this day after day have you been stung
by the criticism I'm very proud of what
the men have been doing I'm very proud
of the officers we're extremely
experienced in public order policing we
have fantastically experienced
commanders we have fantastically
experienced people on the ground we are
world leaders in public order policing
and in protest policing the guys and
girls have been working immensely hard
they have to work within the legal
framework and we have to have a
proportionate response
I'm sure people sitting in their
armchairs you know on one side or other
of the equation may feel I'd have done
it differently but I can assure you
they're thinking through all their
decisions the people on the front line
are more scrutinized probably than any
other profession in the world they're
having every single action filmed and
scrutinized and I think they're doing a
fantastic job and I'm really grateful to
them what happens in the days to come
we've heard your message to the
protesters to gold to Marble Arch and
protests where they were told to
peacefully and legally how much longer
will this last frame well that's up to
the protesters it to some extent isn't
it but we have already arrested over 700
people I think heading for 750 people we
will continue to arrest people we will
continue to dismantle street furniture
take away things that they put in our
way continue to try to minimize
disruption and get the roads moving and
allow people to go about their lawful
business and we will continue to do that
we have shown that we are strong we are
determined I've never I've been a police
officer for 36 years I have never known
an operation a single operation in which
over 700 people have been arrested it
shows we are determined and we will
carry on some reports that you've run
out of cells that you've run out of
officers to arrest people because
they're not cooperating the members of
the protests and it's taking four
officers to carry each person over and
they're arrested just can we talk about
resources and numbers have you run out
of cells
so what many of these protesters are
doing as you will have seen is either
gluing themselves or using very very
sophisticated mechanical contraptions to
make it extremely hard for the officers
to arrest them they therefore have to
spend quite a long time getting people
free using specialist equipment
specialist officers sometimes getting
the glue unglued and then the people are
refusing to walk so they are being
carried I think it is frankly amazing
and I'm very proud of the fact that
nobody has been injured as far as I can
see in any of these arrests but it does
take four or five officers
just to get somebody across to the van
and then they have to be transported to
ourselves
so that's resource intensive but we have
to do our job professionally and we are
doing it professionally once we're at
the custody Suites
of course there's a limited number of
cells in London we have a very good way
of managing the flow around the custody
Suites
we've still got cell space available at
the moment if it comes to the point
where we need to use cells in other
parts of the country and surrounding
forces then of course we would
and that's quite normal sometimes other
forces put people in our cells have you
spoken to the Prime Minister about
what's been going on I am NOT going to
tell you who and who I have spoken to
and who I haven't spoken to but I can
assure you I've spoken to many senior
politicians continue to do so I've got
an open line to both the mayor and
indeed to the Home Secretary they're
taking an interest what happens however
in terms of the operations on the ground
remain entirely the responsibility of
the Metropolitan Police British
Transport Police City of London police
and our partners and we will direct how
the protests are policed the buck stops
with me the protests haven't ended now
but will you be taking away learning
from what's happened over the past few
days in terms of this never happening
again London being effectively brought
to a standstill
so I think we should all pause we always
do after any large-scale or any
small-scale for that matter operation we
will pause in the met and have a good
think about whether there's anything we
could do differently what we've learned
from this how we adapt our tactics we
will also be talking to the government
and to our colleagues in the criminal
justice system to see whether there are
changes that should be made in the legal
framework to make it easier for us to
deal with people who are not violent but
are refusing to move when it is unlawful
for them to stay there protesting any
longer that is the dilemma
and if our powers are insufficient if we
don't have sufficient deterrence in the
criminal justice system then I will
certainly be asking for changes but I
don't think now is the time to go into
the detail of that we obviously need to
think about it
just looking ahead next weekend along
the marathon takes place a huge strain
on police resources as well so many
visitors coming in so many athletes what
happens if these protests are still
ongoing and you've got a world-class
event in the city taking up all of those
resources as well what's your message to
the protesters looking forward to the
next week well my message to protesters
thinking about Sunday marathon Sunday is
that I think a very very large number of
people right across the United Kingdom
would be furious if if the marathon was
affected in terms of its safety and
security or in any other way by protests
like these suffice to say the
Metropolitan Police is a huge service we
are continuing to run our business we're
here where you can see the emergency
calls are being answered we're dealing
with violent crime in all the boroughs
the officers are working extended hours
in order to be able to make that happen
we will continue to adapt and to flex
and continue if we need to with this
operation policing protests and if we
need to ask for help from others other
forces as we have done in the last
couple of days we will do so as I say
I'm very proud of what we've achieved
Heathrow has not been disrupted over 700
people have been arrested the officers
have been extraordinarily professional
and we will go on doing that and trying
to ensure that disruption to people in
general going about their business in
London is minimized as far as possible
the easiest way that can happen is if
these protesters go to Marble Arch we'll
go home so in all your policing
experience you've never known an
operation like this you you would never
do anything differently over the last
few days looking back I've said already
I think there will be bound to be things
that collectively we our partners people
in the criminal justice system and
indeed probably politicians in terms of
you know the legal framework will want
to think about how can we change we
always do that you know if I was running
a firearms operation today at the end of
it the guys and girls will debrief and
they'll say what did we learn from that
how will we do things differently I'm
proud of the professional and
proportionate response of my office
I'm proud by the determination the
resilience and the courage that they're
showing in the face of a quite a lot of
difficulty and pride at how dynamically
they're changing their approach when
they need to and the fact that we have
nobody who's been injured and 750 people
locked up